[Music] It's
not the first time I'm surprised by the ufo I see with me It's not the first time
I've seen that information before I'm okay now
What's happening What's going to happen
I don't take a stance but now I shouldn't think it's related to the first thing I'm saving
So, as I said in Misawa News, Cooper Zoo was caught by a male beast.
It was really good that I was caught. I
couldn't decorate the exam. It's okay
. I'm not injured.  Shiga was kidnapped by the music he went to when he was in the United States
.
55 Let me explain to you from the rear with a pet collar on behalf of Miso.
I'm a pier with shrimp I used to be a so-called pet-like position in the rear with edy and Cooper's Town, Mouth,
but now I'm Misa-sama's pet, Dave Misa-sama's ally, and everyone's ally
.  Hey